préférez-vous aussi le direct en matière
de télévision
ah oui bah oui nous les plus chauds mon
nom mais on a fait des trucs plein de
trucs en direct on a eu un bébé tas
d'émissions directes il est perdu et qui
c'est qui ce sauveur il passe les
mooseheads qui tombait c'est pourquoi
maintenant vous avez les veaux vaches et
moustache qui tombe le verdict
j'ai vu des cameramen en cote de maille
mois dernier au ghana pour qu'ils
puissent passer dans le champ et que de
téléspectateurs ne remarquerait rythme
et en jambes ça il annonce au niveau où
il ya une présence complètement négative
pour ça fait rien c'est pas trop grave
là-bas ça donnera un petit peu de
caractère à mon âge tu me laisses un oui
mais par pour autant perdre en
s'allumant fin des signes cadrés sur moi
je suis assise non elle fait non